ما الذي يشترك فيه كل من Ghostface Killah Paris Hilton
و Floyd
Mayweather إنهم يحاولون جميعًا الاستفادة من اتجاه جديد
أعتقد أنك ربما سمعت عن
الاكتتاب العام الأولي من قبل وأن ICO يختلف قليلاً
أثناء الاكتتاب العام ، يشتري المستثمرون
الأسهم التي تترجم  في
حصص ملكية تلك الشركة ولكن في العرض
الأولي للعملات ، يعرضون عملة أولية
يشترون الرموز المميزة للعملات المشفرة مثل Bitcoin ولكن
تلك التي تم إنشاؤها بواسطة شركة
معينة والتي تحدد العملة المشفرة التي تستثمر فيها ،
إن وجدت ، يمكن أن تكون مربكة بعض الشيء ،
فهناك أكثر من ألف عملة مشفرة
العملات المتداولة في الوقت الحالي مع
تقديم المزيد كل يوم تقريبًا ، يقول
إليوت هان ، المدير الإداري
لبنك الاستثمار الذي يركز على التشفير ،
مجموعة Argonne Group ، إنه يمكنك التفكير في
هذه الرموز الرقمية مثل الرموز
التي تستخدمها للعب لعبة أركيد
خلال ICO هناك  نوعان من الرموز التي
يمكنك شراؤها ، الأول هو رمز الأداة المساعدة
الذي يُقصد استخدامه في السلع
والخدمات التي تقدمها الشركة التي
طورت تلك العملة المشفرة  عملة هذا
يشبه تمامًا عندما تذهب إلى صالة ألعاب
وتتبادل الأموال مقابل رموز لعب اللعبة
التي من المفترض استخدامها في الأجهزة
في ذلك الموقع المحدد وليس في
أي مكان آخر ، يُطلق على النوع الثاني من الرموز
رمز الأمان الذي لا يعني ذلك
أنها أكثر أمانًا ، يشير الأمان إلى
الأوراق المالية التي تشتريها
في الشركة كما تفعل في الاكتتاب العام
ولكنك لا تحصل على الأسهم التي تأتي مع
الأسهم العادية ، فلماذا تشتري
في التوقع هو أن هذه
الرموز  تستحق شيئًا ما في نهاية المطاف
بمجرد أن تطور تلك الشركة طريقة
للناس لإنفاقها إذا ارتفع الطلب ،
يمكن للمستثمرين في وقت مبكر بيع الرموز المميزة الخاصة بهم
لتحقيق ربح ولكن حتى يحدث ذلك ،
فأنت تقوم ببعض المقامرة سيكون
الأمر كما لو كان لدى صديقك خطط  لفتح
رواق جديد وأقنعك بشراء
الرموز مقدمًا ، قال إنه سيكون هناك
عدد محدود فقط في التداول
وأنت على ثقة من أن هذه الرموز في النهاية
ستكون ذات قيمة بمجرد فتح الممرات على
الرغم من أنني الآن  إن
التفكير في الكثير من التمنيات أيضًا
حتى تضع الحكومة إرشادات واضحة لكيفية
استخدام العملات المشفرة
للاستثمار فيها يمكن أن يكون محفوفًا بالمخاطر
للغاية وكما رأينا مع Bitcoin ،
يمكن أن يكون السوق متقلبًا ، وقد
نشرت سنغافورة دليل أفضل ممارسات ICO في
الصين
بإيقاع  أنشأت SEC وحدة إلكترونية
للتحقيق في سوء السلوك ، لكن لا تزال عمليات تحسين محركات البحث (SEO)
غير منظمة بشكل واضح مثل الاكتتابات العامة
في الولايات المتحدة ومعظم البلدان الأخرى مما
يسهل على المحتالين
الاستفادة ولكن ما إذا كانت العملة المشفرة هي في
الواقع مستقبل المال أم مجرد
عابر  بدعة ستسمع الكثير
عن icos في الأشهر المقبلة بينما
يحاول المستثمرون جني الأموال
ويحاول المشرعون تنظيمها